I'm a perfectionist to a fault which is
a strength and also very much an
Achilles heel and I I carry that into
the podcasting that I do in the writing
and everything that I do and it makes me
a bit of a control freak and I think
ultimately it caps my growth my journey
has been about learning to focus on the
things that I do best that other people
can't do and and learning to let go and
Empower other people around me to do the
other tasks and that's challenging for
me because I want to have my pause on
everything that idea like oh only I can
do it you know that's just an ego driven
thing that will just drive your business
and your life into the ground